- [Narrator] Tucked away
in the attic apartment
of this nondescript Wichita
home, is a quixotic filmmaker.
R.G. Miller is 53 year old auteur
who's making home movies with
the scope of blockbusters.
And, when it comes to his self-described
Internet art films, R.G. does it all.
- [R.G.] At RG Studios,
I'm the director,-
- Action.
- [R.G.] the producer, the writer...
- [Narrator] The editor, the actor,
the prop master, you name it.
- [R.G.] I wear many hats.
- [Narrator] He's been doing it that way
for nearly 40 years,
with prolific results.
- Cut.
- [R.G.] All together,
I've made 46 films.
(triumphant music)
(screaming)
- [Narrator] R.G.'s Internet art films,
like any film, start with a script.
- [R.G.] Like any film
coming out of Hollywood,
a real good one, there has to be
a little bit of yourself in there,
or else what's the point?
That's where my storylines
for me come from.
It's an expression within.
For Hardliner it's the expressions
of dealing with society.
- [Narrator] From there
it's on to prop, costume
and set design, which R.G.
handles in his own way.
- [R.G.] You see over my shoulder,
you see chief back here, the boss.
That was an old mask that I had.
I cut it up and I started placing them,
like you would a puzzle,
on a plastic bottle.
That fit the description in my mind.
I think that's kinda the voice I want.
Whatever that takes by making whatever.
What do you think?
- Welcome to hell.
- [Narrator] Next up, R.G.
gets into character
by drawing inspiration from his life,
including some of its darker moments.
- [R.G.] I'm processing my
expressions, my emotions,
my anger, my fits and my addictions.
Trying to be perfect and flawless, Chief!
That's the illusion that we are under!
Don't you know this already?
Making these films has replaced
the addiction that I once had.
By coming here and making my studio,
RG Studios, this is an addiction,
but it's a process addiction,
because I'm examining it.
I'm not allowing it to consume me,
like I did the drugs and the alcohol.
- [Narrator] Once the scene is shot,
R.G. cuts together his vision.
- For me, the best part of
making Internet art films
is the actual process
of putting it together.
- [Narrator] And the results are
unlike anything you've ever seen.
- [R.G.] You're not supposed
to leave the crime scene.
I was hungry, Chief!
- [Narrator] Even after all his hard work,
crowds aren't exactly
flocking to Miller's films.
- I will probably get an average between
two and three people
a week that will watch
something on my Internet YouTube channel.
- [Narrator] Why keep doing
this with little to no audience?
- [R.G.] For me, they are therapeutic.
Ah phooey.
My films allow me to examine my emotions.
Once you examine something,
you can edit out the
things that you don't like,
or you can change the things
that you have an opportunity
to change to your satisfaction.
You did good, son,
-Yes sir, commander
You did good.